how can we help that we get to 10,000 a
month in sales for her art so we can so
she can continue to help people what do
you think oh there be some more value
for reward the word it yeah I think that
that's an awesome awesome thing so what
she's trying to do online is she said
ten thousand dollars of art per month
well I would want to just find out more
about maybe what her market is i don't i
don't know Evan you're gonna have to
answer that one because I I know you've
got so much more knowledge in the art
out of profit over your visual art
alright cool uncle uncle on it okay and
talking about the art world I think I
think the concept of course selling is a
super important almost more important
than than then a lot of other industries
and the idea of course selling is you
know what do you you're selling what you
stand for as opposed to just selling
your products or services are the
benefits associated with it a lot of
people can't understand art you need to
explain what your art means right if I
look at a painting it might be hard for
me just to say oh that's a really good
painting i'm going to go buy that thing
but if I know that you so you know you
left you left your job and started to go
all in on your on yourself after nine
eleven so I don't know the theme is to
you like what your one word is what
you're all about if it's overcome if
it's challenge if it's you know
something around betting on yourself if
it's confidence if it's passion you know
whatever it is you know if you're
capturing that spirit of doing your
thing and being in the moment now and
not waiting for the future like if
that's what your theme is all about
since that's what you did with your
business if that's expressed in your
paintings whatever is expressed like a
good painting a good piece of music you
know any piece of art is only great if
there's emotion in it right like a good
painter
expresses emotion through their art the
challenges you can always see that
emotion if I'm emotional I get all
excited and I'm yelling at ranting
you'll see it very clearly you'll see
clearly if you you know if there's a
singer who's singing their song and you
know you could tell they're almost on
the verge of breaking down because it's
so sad because it's a love song or it's
a it's no they lost somebody you feel
that emotion with them painting is
harder because you you're you're pouring
your guts out onto this canvas and
you're having an emotional connection
and emotional reaction or you should if
you're I'm just going to paint the bird
today great like that that's you know
that's not your like you could do better
but the person seeing it can understand
that connection and so it's on you to
explain it tell me what I'm looking at
tell me why you you're here to do what
you do and I get that you're on a
mission and you want to help people and
it comes across in your in your message
and your loving and consider it and so
letting people know that what is the
mission that you're on how do you
express it to the yard so that I can own
a piece of that right so that if I am
you know the person who hasn't bet on
himself yet or I want to continue to
remind myself to bet on myself and take
those risks or take that chance or
whatever it is that you stand for then
by having your thing on the wall that's
a constant inspiration to me mmm but if
I don't know what I'm looking at is just
a nice piece of art then it's a lot
harder to get that sail and the impact
that you want like you can impact people
through a lot more than just making ten
thousand dollars a month all right you
can impact people through the work
through whom every time they look at
like I walk in here these you know the
people behind me that those canvases
that Jer eyes help me actually make
those mean something to me and they're
just faces on the wall but the faces
represent something
they represent something powerful to me
when I walk in the room your art needs
to represent something and it does to
you but you have to express that to
others so that I want to sign up and i
want to buy your thing because i know
what you stand for so core selling sent
apply it is powerful